hi in this video I'm going to solve
another question from IIT GM 2016 and
this is question from biotechnology
paper this question asked of the given
isomers of molecule 1 and molecule to
the meso form is these first one and the
second one they give to molecule and
they wonder which one is the meso form
so look at the first molecule carefully
and draw the Fischer projection for the
first molecule if we draw the Fischer
projection for the first molecule it
would somewhat look like this so here we
have ch3 here we have ch3 on the other
side it have bromine hydrogen let's say
chlorine here and hydrogen here so this
configuration could be changed but what
is actually a meso form meso form means
we have to we are able to dissociate the
molecule from the middle say here is a
mirror so this portion would be the
exact mirror or
image for the second portion now if we
try to draw a mirror from the centre of
this molecule this portion could not be
the mirror image of this portion as this
chlorine and bromine are different if we
even rotate that if we use an R or s
form doesn't matter it can't be a mirror
image so whenever we get a option with
molecule one those option could not be
correct so first of all these two
options are excluded now we would see
the compound 2 if we analyze the
compound to compound 2 would somewhat
look like this so either if it has
chlorine in both this side
or the chlorine could be here also and
hydrogen could be here but this form is
miss of one because if we draw a mirror
from the center the upper part is
exactly the mirror image for the lower
part now the trick is we have to look
for the RS nomenclature for these two
stereo centers and we have to choose one
of these options so if we talk about
this stereo Center top priority group
would be this chlorine because chlorine
has the higher molecule highest
molecular weight among all the group
groups over here so here second priority
group would be this chiral carbon and
third priority group would be this and
remember hydrogen is over here so the
rotation would be like 1 2 2 then 2 2 3
in a counterclockwise direction but as
hydrogen is over here so as hydrogen is
over here this rotation is happening in
the clockwise direction the rotation is
happening in a clockwise direction we
would write it as s now here it is the
first what this is the first one and the
second group is this chiral carbon the
third group is like this so the rotation
would go like 1 2 2 then 2 2 3 and this
is the counterclockwise this is the
counterclockwise and it looks like it
would be s but it would be actually our
okay so we got our and this
configuration if one stereo Center is in
our configuration and other Studios
entry is in s configuration then we
would get a Mesa compound now if we look
at the option this option is this option
is correct and the other option is not
correct because if if both are in s
configuration they want to be a Mesa
compound they would look like the fourth
option would somewhat look like fluorine
here chlorine here so this would be 1
this would be SS configuration so this
option is incorrect so the correct
option is this so basically you have to
understand all
not about this IRS nomenclature because
RS vermin creature is really helpful to
solve any question similar type of
question was asked in IIT JM 2013 so
this question is actually reputation and
this cush this type of question using RS
form and feature is repeated many times
so this RS nomenclature is very
important for IIT JM biotechnology hope
you enjoyed the video please subscribe
and like thank you